hello everyone and welcome to another
game from day one of the st. Louis rapid
M let's tournament it's the wild card
Richard report vs. Magnus Carlsen
so across and with a loss from Game one
now faces report and a lot we have
suggested it so it's a really great game
and for those of you who really miss
meadow I decided to put instead of the
painting behind me this very nice photo
of meadow with a nice flower in his hair
so there you have it hope you enjoyed
that as well now let's check out the
game report with the white pieces opens
with Knight to f3 sorry about that so we
have the red on the board we have
defiled by crossing and we have g3
starting the Kings Indian attack now
with Bishop to g4 cross and goes for the
chaos variation and now bash up the g2 I
think I too enjoy preparing Castle with
ethics by Magnus and now c4 just
challenging the center column
strengthens it with c6 we have castles
by report Knight to f6 and now seek a
person b5 a one trade in the center
first cousin gets rid of the night here
with Bishop captures Bishop captures and
seek a person d5 so here across and
decides to give up the bishop pair early
in the game but if white is unable to do
something about blacks stronger chain
here white flight square Bishop also
might not be all that great a report
continues with d4 with Knight to c6 and
now III with Bishop to e7 cross him
prepares the Castle kingside Knight to
c3 and we have just castles Quinte - and
now rook the c8 by magnus putting a rock
on a nice open c file and now there are
seven games i believe in the database
worship the deity was played but here we
have rook to d1 by report now it is a
new move but it's not really a new move
as we will once again transpose into
some of the games that were played
before with Queen d7
developing the Queen connecting rooks by
Magnus and now Bush of the d2 with rook
FD 8 now both of the rooks are nicely
developed the ship T 1 now the rook and
the D file is again very strong and nice
the e8 Crossan is ready to now push f5
to really control the e4 square and
prevent efore from ever being
Flay played by Robert now there is one
game where Bishop - G - was played but
here cross a Robert plays rook a to see
one and it is now a completely new game
on our hands
also you could think about playing
something like e for here with the idea
that if maybe captures captures with the
Queen and now if Knight captures you can
maybe capture on b7 but it doesn't work
because Crossin here it has Knight f6
and now you have to move the Queen you
lose the pawn and there is no
compensation for this free pawn so look
a c1 a new move by report and Carson has
to now play a completely new game with
f5 by Carson now efore is never an issue
here with Bishop back to g2 and now
comes Knight to f6 now that f5 has been
played this Knight is returning to f6 94
could be an idea in the future we'll see
we have Knight to a4 by Robert one
wanting to go to c5 cross and prevents
that of course and now as the knight no
longer has anything to do an a4 just
night back to c3 and Carlsen does the
same knife day five trying to get b3
from Robert for example if b3 then you
could go for some Bishop e3 harassing
the rope maybe trying to win the C file
and then after c2 it's not really a
useful rook and c2 because you will not
be able to double rooks on the C file
cross and we'll just play rock c6 double
up rooks on the C file and it is a small
accomplishment which you know if you
don't have to give black you don't don't
give it give him anything
so instead nice to be one allowing night
c4 but offering a trade of rooks Carlson
plays Knight c4 and now rook to c2
putting more defense to the B to pawn
also preparing now to double up rooks
and the C file because if in that line
Bishop e3 prevented exactly that and
here even though Carson lost game 1 to
think he is not discouraged from
starting an attack on the Kings side
with g5 Robert continues with his
planned route d c1 and now g4 like alpha
0 grabbing more space on the King side
Bishop to f1 as we already mentioned the
bishop will not be very useful on this
diagonal and now Knight to e4 as you
cannot capture the knight the bishop is
now on f1 with b3 pushing the knight
back Knight to d6 now
here there is this support about the
board that we often use even a bad plan
is better than no plan but there is it
means that if you start something it's
better than starting nothing if you
start nothing then a good player will
easily punish that but it's there's also
a saying that says I don't know if
there's like a real really a saying
about that if you realize what your
opponent is doing there's really no need
to stop it if it's a bad plan just allow
him to execute it and you know his
position should deteriorate by itself
here is one such example that maybe
happened
we have Quinta a6 by report his idea is
a4 a5 he wants to create weaknesses here
to attack cross and plays rook captures
on CT we have rook captures and c2 and
now just king of seven improving the
position of a scheme with a four by
report preparing a5 and cross and
continues his attack on the Kings side
with h5 end now a5 crossing goes rogue
ba it defends the b6 pawn we have
captures captures and then out comes
Queen to a2 and here
Carlson plays Queen to b7 and there is
no good way of defending the b3 pawn
here if you play something like before
then you free the c-4 square for
Carlson's night and now you have two
monster Knights here the c4 and the e4
Knight which you would probably have to
capture and even if you lose a pawn here
it's not a problem because 85 now
prevents you from capturing if you
capture you lose the night here so you
would have to play some like Queen c7
even after a queen trade you get a
capture some before and now Carson would
have this powerful pass be pawn and
white would have a very hard time for
stopping it so here Robert finds a very
active plan Bishop to a5 he gives up the
b3 pawn for this rook the c7 lifts as
the bishop now is guarding the c7 square
cross and calculates it right with
lookout for Sun b3r up the c7 and now
Queen back to b8 and you don't want the
night and we want to remain a target
Knight to be 2 as the bishop also guards
the night here so what do you play here
here Carlsen found a very nice idea rook
to be to just attacking the Queen and
seems to be winning the piece a report
had this planned out with Quinta a4 and
now Magnus just
grab the piece with knife capture sandy
- and now Queen to d7 now threatening to
capture the bishop here but this does
not work so here Crossin first plate
knight of three checked with King - h1
and now feel free to pause the video and
try to find a very nice finishing touch
Magnus used to ended this game well I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are once again an
excellent sacrificer of the Queen and
this time not even a temporary 128 is
possible but much much better as Queen
captures on c7 and it was in fact in
this position that we shall drop or
resign the game he's already down one
piece now the Queen just grabbed the
rook so he can capture the Queen but
there is no good follow up if Queen
captures just 94 and White has no moves
you can't get this Bishop over here to
attack the pinned piece you can get it
to be for as the rook covers before
knife captors and f2 is a terrible
threat you cannot defended the knight
also covers II won now whatever you play
with say Quincy won just Knight captures
on f2 and White will not be in time to
capture the rook Kings you to only move
now 91 check it doesn't matter if you
captured with the bishop or with the
Queen 93 I discovered check will pick up
the Queen so you could play something
like this
a 93 check a discovered check from the
rook Queen blocks captures captures and
Knight just moves but here it's an
endgame where cousin is up two points
and you don't play an endgame or cross
and his off two pawns and after 91 check
if you don't capture it you could just
move the King let's say you try kingi
one still not if three check King still
has to go to g2 and now 93 check will
just pick up the Queen there's no way
around at Queen kept person b2 Knight
captures and well it's just just a
terrible position for white still down
two pawns there there's no playing this
but not only that he's also down down a
piece so even worse and yeah after Queen
captures on c7 Robert decided that was
it were not playing this game so a very
nice comeback by Magnus in this
tournament first losing game onto ding
then beating report with you know with
great style we're not gonna discuss the
standings just yet we're gonna
enjoy some of the games a bit more and
then we're gonna show the standings but
yeah I really hope you enjoyed it
that was the game I would like to thank
mmm in the end a video for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
video serie thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the st. Lewis
reppin the Blitz event continuing the
capablanca saga and of course checking
up on your suggestions thank you all I
will see you soon have an excellent rest
of your day and I'm now returning to
enjoy my vacation
see you soon